Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Whack Your Boss 2.
Now, this might actually be made by the same guy that made the original Whack your Boss.
Which is really cool, considering all the other whacking games since then have been made by different artsts.
Some good, some not so good,
but mostly, pretty average. (And Brutal)
But it's always good to come back to the original, and this is Whack your boss 2: Fantasy Edition,
and there should be about 10 different ways for us to kill this fucking asshole (lovely person), right here.
BOSS: No, no, no, no, no...
Uh huh.
BOSS: Wrong, wrong wrong..
Yeah, well, well, what else is new?
BOSS: Didn't you get the memo?
NO
BOSS: Here's a fun fact, (uh huh) memos are not created to inform the recipient...
...they're designed to protect the sender.
Oohhh
BOSS: so, how long have you been sitting there?
BOSS: So, how long have you been sitting there?
I have no idea.
BOSS: For 10 years.
10 years? (giggling)
Boss: In that time nothing has changed, except you've
Boss: gotten weaken and I've gotten stronger.
Mark: I- I love *giggles*
Boss: This is heaven...
Mark: I love self aware humor
Boss: ...corporate merges, less government restrictions.
Mark: Uh- huh, whoops, oh I didn't even mean to do that! (Boss gets scanned by beam of light)
I don't know what that did.
Oh! Oh God! (Realises what happened)
Oh no it's Gance! (Guilt Sinks in)
He got teleported to another world or just murdered! (Most likely murdered)
I don't know how that works.
Oh jeez. I don't know why that worked. (Thug Life)
And I don't know what was in your cabinet  that caused that to happen.
Oh boy, thanks Mr Cleaner Man.
And here he comes again, hi Boss, good to see ya!     (Not really)
Boss: No, no, no, no,no...
Mark: No?
Boss: wrong, wrong, wrong.
Mark: No?!
Mark: NO?!
Boss: Didn't you get the memo?
Mark: Not at all.
Boss: Here's a fun fact...
Mark: Oh shit.
Boss: memos are not created to inform the recipient,
there're designed to protect the sender.
Mark: I'm gonna listen to all of these cause I want to hear 'em.
Boss: So, how long have you been sitting there?
Over ten years,...
Mark: Yeah.
Boss: In that time nothing has changed, except you've
gotten weaken and I've gotten stronger.
Mark: Hmm.
Boss: It's been heaven corporate mergers, less
government restrictions. Governments, that's a laugh, I
now have the power to sue governments, They can't
Mark: *confused* What...?
even protect their own intellectual property.
Mark: Oh.
Boss: Which means, I create nothing new,
Mark: Ah.
and I'm proud of it...
Mark: Ooh.
Boss: I simply sit back and wait for someone else to create something,
Mark: *Chuckles* No.
Boss: then I steal it.
Marks: *Laughs*
Boss: What's that? I'm a parasite, of course I am.
Boss: Parasites are survivors, and they will outlive most
species in the impending mass extinction.
Boss: Aw, is that depressing, good.
Mark: I think...
Boss: I want you in a depressed Hell.
Mark:*Laughs*
Boss: Where you won't ask for anything, even this
cubicle was designed to break you down by separating you from your fellows.
Mark:Whoa.
Boss: At the same time it denies you the privacy of a real office.
Boss: Thus, your cubicle takes away your community and privacy.
Mark: Ah.
Boss: Zero dignity, you feel trapped, alone, powerless.
Boss: Have your doctor write you another prescription.
Mark: Oh.
Boss: You wonder how I tolerate this place? Here's a
little secret, I don't like working here, I LOVE IT , I thrive here.
I'm ask my low self-esteem with
corporate buzzwords like vibrant robust
like vibrant, robust, core competency, optics,
Mark: Ahh!
core competency optics sustainability
Mark:ooh
Boss: That's a joke...
Mark: Wow!
Boss: sustainable energy projects will cost the company
Way too much money, the environment can wait, oh polar
bears are dying? grizzly bears will handle it.
Boss: As we speak grizzlies are moving north and
mating with polar bears, a whole new species!
Boss: Bees are dying? Switch to agave,
Mark: *Laughs*
Boss: save the whales? Clone the whales.
Mark: * Laughs harder*
Boss: debate that around your little water cooler.
Mark: * Still laughing* I'll try.
Boss: Oh and enjoy that free cup of water it could be
your last. What heard is true, water is the new oil. The
water wars aren't coming, there're already here.
Mark: Oh okay.
Boss: Didn't you get the memo?
Mark: *Laughing* I don't think I did.
Mark: Oh man....
"Help our hero! click something in the cubicle..."
Man I was having a great time listening to him and I'm
pretty sure some of that was commentary  on the other whacking games.
In terms of, stealing other people's work. Anyway, so,
alright hang on I gotta find, alright. My own hand, whoaa!
*Chuckles*
Ohhh ho, ho, ho oh God, what is that? (I'm pretty sure those are organs)
What is that?!
What is that?!! Ugh!
Ugh okay! No one saw your murder, you're fine. (Besides millions of viewers online)
Whoaa, oooh.
Wooo-oh.
So...
habosky, haplff, haplff! Oh...
Oh no, no...
Whoa, God.
*Disgusted noises* EW!!
Something about the original guy, he just makes it so horrifying.
I mean there's been some, like... bad ones
since then, but something about the original and the way
they just, like obliterate these people, these poor, I mean
he's an asshole, obviously, but my goodness.
*Surprised* Ahh!
Oh okay, nice ass.
Alrighty- how- I don't think they're equipped with a hose,
I'm pretty sure- Oh jeez. Wha... the arms, why the arms first? (Because... Game Logic)
I know human anatomy and that's... oh boy
Eww!
That's a lot of blood.
That seemed like more blood than-  Why are YOU not covered in blood? (Video Game logic)
Don't look at me!
I have a few questions. He could have spat it out at any time
There wasn't even enough... *Chuckles* anyway.
Logic aside, ugh, oh, man, having people like blow up is
one of the worst ways that I can possibly imagine a
death in like a movie or a game, like I still get nightmares....
Whooaa- oh!
BOSS:*High pitched scream
Hey, is it a dildo? *Chuckles* Okay bye, peace.
Ooohhh, it was not a dildo, I mean it's a dildo if you're brave enough.
I mean, wouldn't you want your last act to be  shoving a nuke up your butt?
No...? *Laughing*
I don't think a cleaner- how does a cleaner gonna be- I
mean, I know a lot of cleaners but- oh the other hand.
The back hand.
Ugh! I know- how- why and how- (Use the force)
*disturbed and disgusted noises*
Oh man.
The original is always best, I suppose- how about the other drawer?
Oh no! It is Sat-an, well good-bye then
Oh goodness gracious!
*Laughing*  Okay
Oh great!
Wonderful!
Awesome!
*Chuckling* They did it, they're so happy. (Yay!)
*Laughing* Oh wow!
Oh boy, I love this, I love it there's nothing quite like the original.
I- I gotta say, nothing at all.
Hello, let me just pull this out of my... well hello,
hi, hi, how you doing. (I'm doing great)
Oh goody, good, ah okay, that's not normal.
Well....
it's bad that you were standing exactly there.
*Laughing* Oh no! Oh no!
Oh God! No! Why are prancing there the meadow
with him on you? Oh no! (Looks like fun!)
That's not good...Oh it's pretty good.
I guess it's pretty good, I mean this van- fan- fantasy
edition for a reason, I suppose.
Oh boy.
This is so awesome, oh here we go. Oh!
*Orchestra music
Ah! Aaahh!
Yeah!! The giant alien hands from the sky, perfect!
Huh-uh... (He's still smiling)
Oooohhhh.... (He died with a smile on his face)
*Orchestra music ends
Well...
*Laughs* Thanks for that, this guys is like
Well I didn't plan any of that, that just happened.
Holy shit, oh, oh here we go.
Um.... sir uh..
Why- why does that make you happy?
BOSS:*giggles
Uh-oh!
BOSS:Ahh!
Uh, move. Ohhhhh...
ohh..ohhh, ohhh *Giggles*
Well...
if I'm not mistaken that's the end of "Whack Your Boss 2" I mean the original- Heyyy
NY
I win! I feel so- Oh hi
Oh that's man poor lumbar. Oh...
Ah good, he's been rescued. (Smiling again)
Is he going to do it again, is he falling for the same trick?
Oh...Oh!
The ultimate punishment. Oh man...
That was awesome. (GG)
Tom winkler who is probably the original
artists of all these games and a bunch
of other stuff too
a lot of them poop related I've checked
them out,
there's a lot of poop. But either way thank you so much for
making this and thank you everybody so much for watching it.
It's awesome, it's good to get back to the originals, I gotta admit
so, thank you again, you can check out the other Whacking
games in the description below or through the
annotations over there and thanks, again.
And as always I will see you in the next video, buh-bye!
*outro music*